hey i'm tanner buchanan i play robbie
key hi i'm mary mauser and i play
samantha larusso i'm peyton list i play
tory nichols hi i'm shola madidunya and
i'm miguel diaz hi my name is jacob
scott thomas bertrand and i play hawk hi
i'm gianni dicenzo and i play dimitri
and we're the cast of cobra kai and
today we're here with buzzfeed to play a
little game of who's who
[Music]
who's most likely to start laughing and
break character show
and it's always on the dumbest thing
it's always like prolonged looking like
if i if one of us looks at each other
for like a second
it's just like oh no
i feel like you make yourself laugh
i'm just that funny what can i say i
just uh i'm a natural born comedian who
is most likely to nail a stunt on the
first take
i'll just say show low i feel like
whenever show and i first do choreo he
always has a little bit better than i do
and then we go to coyote creek and
yeah i know i feel like we've kind of
all been good and bad about that at
different times but i feel like peyton
and i are always we're always hot and
ready to take on the next challenge
it makes sense that's the jacob jacob
you got the you got the hops they got
the hat i think mary i think you and i
nail everything on the first take thank
you yeah i agree peyton i'm just here
for the ride
who's most like their cobra kai
character peyton maybe probably peyton
yeah
what did you say you're a nightmare now
we're going for it it's peyton i think
it's i think we all think it's peyton i
think she's just
violent as a monster wait that was so
tory of you you can't flip off the
camera
you're saying i'm a nerd right that
deserves to get beaten up okay yeah but
you got the girl yeah that's true i
didn't get the girl thank you very much
you deserve the whole world gianni you
deserve it all buddy i kind of regret
saying you're like tory now but not me
thank you who's the least like their
cobra kai character mary jacob
i think jerry too oh yeah no no no
no i'll take that i'll take not being
like samantha i was gonna say oh but
she's like the girl next door so what
are you saying i am but no one likes
samantha anyway so okay yeah that's not
true
i don't think tanner's super like robbie
that's what i said that was my answer
too yeah but i feel like it's you jacob
i mean you don't have a back tattoo
my
yeah
is literally a psychopath so i feel like
if you were to say me i'd be like yo
come on what the heck guys
no jacob you are a lot like hawk i will
say
[Laughter]
who is the best at doing impressions of
other cast members
jacob jacob you love to rock that
scottish accent that's a classic who's
most likely to randomly burst into song
on set
you were singing disney songs on during
the scene once i remember because it was
your it was the nightmare secrets
sequence before i had to beat you up and
i was like i can't do this she's singing
disney songs
usual morning
[Laughter]
do you want a [ __ ]
who would you trust to give you
relationship advice gianni
i feel like he's probably the most
wholesome out of all of us i think
that's true
one good egg i haven't gone rotten yet
thank you no you don't want my my
romance advice trust me i'm a nightmare
nixon he's like i'm a bad boy
[Laughter]
he's like i'm
i'm a toxic user you know you don't want
none of this ladies are scared of how
much they love me
who's most likely to send a funny meme
or video to a group chat with the cast
haters
oh yeah gianni that was not me who
didn't add you to the group chat
oh i just got this is a new wow okay
oh my god who created it
who's most likely to win a game of
karate kid universe trivia mary just
because sherry
i feel like she would look at her
i feel like she was probably curious
when i was like oh i thought you were
saying i would you know like that's rude
but yeah that's like you marry
someone still butt hurt about the group
chad who is most likely to be caught
taking a selfie tanner what banner that
was so quick
what are you doing why are you trying to
start a war right now no no i have a
funny story about we were filming the
russo house fight in season three hannah
was on set and he came to watch and i
just remember like sitting down at the
table it was like in between scenes and
i just look over and like in one of the
hallways there's like one light dangling
and tanner's like i have a video of that
shout out about it is like taking a
selfie like in the lighting we made eye
contact for a split second and he went
back to the selfie yeah
i'm always trying to fix my hair who's
most likely to throw a party after work
i would say peyton jacob
i mean i might only be saying that
because i feel like the only time we've
hung out as a group really was at
peyton's other than the time at my place
at the park i guess it depends on your
definition of party like yeah
okay the people that's like magic night
mary
you're wanting snacks you asked mary to
host the party because mine was just
snacks from my cabinet that were left
over and mary called me out on it
but we had pizza we had pizza at your
party yeah that's true who's most likely
to pull a prank on set i'm going to say
tango jacob literally all the time while
we're in scenes together he's kicking me
he's shoving me he's like
a makeup prank he like trades places oh
yeah wait no no no mary pulled a prank
on me this season that a bunch of people
knew about she
he basically was like oh my gosh we're
gonna scare jacob and you decided this
like it was like a two-week long prank
they wanted me to think that jamie our
lead makeup artist like i think i you
she like cut you or something yeah then
she like knocked me out yeah so jamie
comes running out of the little section
of that mary gets her makeup done is
like oh my god like sprints out i
screamed blood murder
and i was like what the heck i assume i
was like okay there's a lizard over
there like i got it
there's a ladybug
i start walking over there and i just
see mary like slumped over and i was
like oh
she had diabetes she's probably really
low right now or something oh my god
she's gonna die so i freaked out and i
was like mary mary and i was getting my
makeup destined to have my mascot and i
was like oh i don't want to walk over
too close to her so i like walked out
and was like guys someone go get help
and she was like trying to like have me
come over and then go like and scare me
but i never i never walked over there
because i was too afraid he walks up
there and he's like i can hear him going
oh my god oh my god and i'm like waiting
for him to get close to me so that i can
jump out and scare him and then he's
like no this is actually really bad like
she's not conscious like this is
actually really bad i felt so bad well
because i turn around and peyton's in on
the joke recording me and she's laughing
like
and i'm like no this is serious she's
like oh yeah why is it serious like she
has diabetes this is bad
at least i know jacob's got my back
thanks so much for hanging out with us
guys you can watch cobra kai season 4
now on netflix
[Music]
you